Ciao Maryners e benvenuti in un nuovissimo video!
Oggi parliamo di make up, come l'anno scorso ho voluto fare un video facendovi vedere due trucchi
secondo me molto carini per le feste, per il Natale. In particolare, ho deciso di fare il tutorial
di due make up: uno un po' più semplice, un po' più soft, che quello che vedete addosso a me in questo momento
Molto facile da realizzare; uno un pelino più
sofisticato, un po' meno sobrio, un po più Maryna e un po' più carico, quindi anche leggermente più complicato da realizzare
Partiamo subito con il primo make up, quello soft
Per questo make up, ho utilizzato la palette "poison garden" di nabla. Iniziamo subito stendendo "Zen" su l'angolo esterno dell'occhio
Poi enfatizziamo ulteriormente lo sguardo con "opera" e sfumiamo bene.
Infine applichiamo "rosita" con il polpastrello sulla palpebra mobile
Sulla rima ciliare
Inferiore, con un pennellino sono andata ad applicare sempre "opera" e poi anche, una matita rosso scuro, in particolare
ho utilizzato "dark suol" di nyx
Nell'angolo interno, per illuminare lo sguardo, ho applicato "adoration". Poi ho colorato la rima ciliare superiore con una matita marrone, sempre di nyx
Ho applicato il mascara
E infine, sulle labbra, ho applicato un lip gloss sempre, di nabla che si chiama "crazy diamond" e.. voilà!
E dopo un trucco sobrissimo, passiamo un trucco tutt'altro che sobrio perché come potete notare
Ciglia finte, rossetto bello intenso e carico quindi sicuramente un make up più sofisticato, più
Aggressiv, più Maryna. Partiamo subito con il tutorial. Per questo make up invece utilizzato "iconica". In particolare
Ho iniziato stendendo "Marilyn" sull'angolo esterno dell'occhio
Ho sfumato bene e poi ho applicato "coco", sempre sull'angolo esterno. Con un pennellino ho steso sempre "coco" anche sulla rima ciliare inferiore
Poi con il polpastrello ho applicato "grace" sulla palpebra mobile
Il nostro amatissimo eyeliner, sempre presente
Ho applicato il mascara sia sopra che sotto
Il super illuminante di "farsali", le ciglia finte,
E poi sono passata alle labbra: ho disegnato prima il contorno, e poi ho applicato "Choco red" di
Clio. Un bel po' di cipria fissante, la terra
e... voilà!
Siamo arrivati purtroppo alla fine del video, spero tantissimo che vi siano
Piaciuti questi due make up che ho scelto per voi e che chissà magari li possiate utilizzare per le vostre
cene di Natale, per i vostri pranzi di Natale,
Per le vostre feste ecco. Fatemi sapere con un commento qui sotto quale dei due make up avete preferito e come al solito
Se non l'avete ancora fatto
Iscrivetevi al canale e cliccate sulla campanella che trovate vicino al tasso di iscrizione per ricevere
Una notifica  tutte le volte che pubblico nuovi video e mi raccomando
Selezionate tutte le notifiche
Seguitemi anche, su tutti gli altri social facebook instagram e tik tok. Ho pubblicato anche
Ultimamente dei tik tok di make up, diciamo
Quindi seguitemi anche lì e vi mando un bacione enorme. Ci vediamo al prossimo video. Ciao
Adoroo